alertée l'environnement avec peut-être
une nouvelle source d'énergie
renouvelable qui peut intéresser la
france l'hydrolienne il s'agit tout
simplement d'exploiter le mouvement des
marées un prototype a été installé dans
le sud de l'angleterre
laurent boussier dominique marault tél
de loin on dirait une boîte à chaussure
géante ancré à quelques kilomètres des
côtes du devon dans le sud de
l'angleterre de prêt évidemment c'est
autre chose
voici ci flot un concentré d'innovations
et de haute technologie qui pourrait
bien représenter demain une bonne partie
de l'énergie propre et renouvelable de
la planète prototype d'essai grandeur
nature si flo est une hydrolienne une
turbine de 300 kilowatts qui grâce à une
hélice ou marine utilise la force des
courants et des marées pour produire de
l'électricité
la puissance des marais 400 fois
supérieure à celle du genre vous
imaginez on peut donc avoir la même
production d'énergie avec des lycées des
turbines plus petit et avec des vitesses
moins grande
le potentiel énorme
installé au printemps testé depuis le
mois de juillet légèrement modifié si
flou et depuis quelque temps relié au
réseau électrique edf énergies locales
une étape importante qui va permettre
aux ingénieurs de faire évoluer ce
prototype vers la version définitive du
projet cette expérience est une base
pour l'étape suivante la construction du
prototype définitif avec une hélice à
double rotation
selon la marée montante et la marée
descendante pour les concepteurs comme
pour les compagnies d'électricité
l'énergie marine est une des énergies
d'avenir non polluante selon eux il
existe des milliers de sites où ces
hydroliennes pourrait être installé et
il espère un jour faire concurrence aux
champs d'éoliennes que l'on voit fleurir
un peu partout sur la planète